being the first of my family to go to
college there were things I did not know
there were many unknowns and many times
you don't want to give voice to that
because you don't want to be perceived
as less than now it's okay to be in
those particular spaces because you're
unified you are first together when we
first got the little symbol to add to
our email signatures I was like all
right let's try this out it's important
for me to identify myself so people can
find me but then as time went on and I
saw more faculty and academic advisors
and colleagues started putting the first
together in their email signature it was
really kind of exciting because I had no
idea we're building a new community and
anytime that there's new language and
opportunity for people to connect on
this level that they didn't know they
could connect about I think that's just
exciting in and of itself I don't think
it actually hit me that it was a thing
for me for first gen students until I
actually saw the mixture is happening in
the center but the moment that it really
hit home for me was when we had our
provost and other faculty come to the
event and there were just tears and so
many emotions and just being able to see
that that it's you know it's not just me
going through it but it's also other
established you know people at this
university was really great and that's
when that's what I was like so thankful
to be a part of this university I think
like the first together movement is it's
great it's social support it's knowing
that other people care about you and are
like you and you have a community also
having like access to this information
that gets accumulated through lots of
other really excellent people who have
been in the same kinds of situations as
me and have gotten through and so I
think having a way to identify a
community of people who
oh that's someone who gets me or oh
that's someone who's been in the places
I've been and who I could talk to like
not even go to and have them tell me
what to do about everything but just be
able to listen
have any ability to understand where I'm
coming from is super invaluable I guess
where I'm from in my community I'm used
to no one going to college so being in
college just trying to figure out and
even understand you know how do people
communicate how what is the social
spaces like how do you maneuver how do I
even start talking to people and so
that's been some of the challenges that
I've had and you know with the help of
first together they've helped me
overcome some of them you could look at
anybody and like you would have no idea
whether they are a legacy or a first gen
person because Carnegie Mellon's on top
of this there is a growing body of
support of resources of faculty of
alumni that are able to help students
enter Carnegie Mellon and like have
those resources so a student will be
very confident that once they come here
like they got their community they got
people to understand them and like
there's a place for them they are part
of the one CMU experience
[Music]